[Music]
tummy tuck was worse than my srs because
they cut your stomach and they lift the
muscles and that's your core
and so just sneezing farting
coughing dropping something is a
[Music]
i
wish didn't get plastic surgery
three
two
one go
um i had a rhinoplasty and a breast
augmentation it has helped me overcome a
lot of self-image
issues that i've had and i do not regret
my either of those at all however
sometimes i do
wish that i was more natural just
because i feel like society puts a big
emphasis on
you know being naturally beautiful i was
insecure about my breasts before i
didn't like the size i was like you know
maybe if they were a little bigger like
so and i went ahead i i did it
and i
i could never go back
like it makes me so happy like i look at
myself in the mirror and i'm like a damn
girl
where do you come from ma like okay give
me your number i my whole entire life
felt uncomfortable with my boobs because
they were in a regular shape
and that was never going to change
unless i got a surgery i could never
regret it because i feel so much more
confident even though they're not even
like fully dropped and shaped yet hi i
love my plastic surgery i've had over
procedures i had a lot of bad
experiences but i don't regret any of it
it's made me who i am i have a recording
career now because of it as a trans
person who goes through this cis hat
society
people are always nitpicking at my body
they're always like you don't have big
enough boobs you don't have an ass your
face looks up you don't look
feminine you look masculine i kind of
wish that i never got breast
augmentation
not because like it makes me feel any
type of way but more so i wish i didn't
feel like i had to have boobs to feel
pretty
i didn't like my mother pushed that a
lot like you need to look feminine to be
beautiful and i'm like
well you're perfect the way you are and
the way you are always perfect 100 i'm
telling you
i was pretty before my surgery
absolutely a hundred percent i was
beautiful i've always been i still am
and i will be my whole life this was
just a little i have a little salt a
little salt and pepper on top that's it
a little more flavor well my nose
changed my whole life my whole
perception of my face so i i think i'm
beautiful now but before when i look at
pictures i'm like god damn i'm so glad i
got that nice job
i kind of agree with what you're saying
but at the same time i've always felt
like i'm beautiful from the inside out
no matter what anyone else tells me like
just because i didn't fit your beauty
standard back then doesn't mean that i'm
not beautiful now people should be open
about their plastic surgery
it's nobody's in business you know it
isn't you know sometimes i'll tell
people you know i guess i look like a
walking plastic surgery doll but you
know i just
i could care less and you know it's it's
up to the individual you know whether
you want to tell your story or not well
i think when it comes to celebrities and
like influencers like you should be open
about about your plastic surgery because
i think that people like especially like
when they're in a higher they have
higher platforms that they should be
open about it because a lot of people
have had plastic surgery it's like and
you're going around putting it off
can we go to the dentist it's like okay
you don't want to tell me a story that's
okay but don't tell me something's real
and natural
when it's plastic plastic surgery
doesn't hurt that bad my recovery
honestly wasn't that bad they everybody
told me you're gonna be in so much pain
this and that you're not gonna be able
to lift your arms you're not gonna move
i was fine
like two days later i was in the shower
and i took my shirt off i didn't feel it
i'll tell you the worst one was the
tummy tuck
tummy tuck was worse than my srs
everything it was because they cut your
stomach and they lift the muscles and
that's your core
and so just sneezing farting
coughing
dropping something is a
standards like people are usually
not born with perfect buoys or perfect
anything so it definitely does and it's
not just plastic surgery it's the
fillers it's the botox yeah exactly all
the snacks
i sometimes get complimented by people
on the internet being like oh you're
such a natural beauty and i'm like
natural wear baby plastic surgery is a
privilege so as a trans person myself i
feel like plastic surgery is definitely
a privilege because even just being on
hormones for a trans person is a
privilege and not all of them are able
to access
large amounts of money just to get a
procedure because you know they're just
not granted that it's not a privilege
anybody could have it really to me it
sounds like only certain groups certain
you know a socioeconomic group can get
it but anybody can get it and i respect
that but i think having that option
to choose oh i'm gonna go and get my
things done
that is that is privilege and i come
from a third world country you know like
i've seen struggle i've seen bad
so
to me it i'm blessed and i think it is a
privilege some people overdo it with
plastic surgery three
two
one
go
i think if you go to the point in which
it affects your health
nah that is too much so that would be
over doing it but
who are we to say oh that person is
overdoing it just just for the sake of
it you know just because you personally
don't like how they look that's none of
your business that's their body you know
if they're happy it's okay i stopped
when i felt like i needed to stop i
think if i continue to get plastic
surgery i would have started just
tearing myself apart and i feel like
i might have gotten progressively
more
critical of myself i never understood
why people call other people botched i
think that's really up and i
don't think that other people need your
projections onto
what they view as beautiful because the
media preys on female insecurity and
they beat that into your head to want to
look beautiful perfect
all the time
i've gone too far i had liquid silicone
injected in my body from head to toe and
now i'm paying the price now i had it re
taken out of my body maybe 50 times
but they can't ever get rid of it
completely because it's plastic can you
overdo it yeah is it my business no no
welcome i agree with all of you guys
i would let my children get plastic
surgery three
two
one go
if my child was
underage i
wouldn't sign off on it because i would
like them to mature more and elective
surgery i think is
a big emotional role roller coaster the
whole healing process and
getting the operation and
by the time they're 18 that is up to
them and i would support them because
obviously i'd be a hypocrite otherwise i
am from venezuela
and venezuela is very big on plastic
surgery in my country also it's very
common to gift
like quinceaneras
like do you want your nose done a
rhinoplasty if you don't like your nose
you're 16 17 you can be under 18 and you
get that as a as a birthday present i
just i would support them with whatever
they wanted but at the same time
i have to ask them why they would want
to get that in the first place like did
i not give you enough validation as a
young person to
feel more comfortable in your skin like
i guess i would want to know where it
comes from before i give them the okay
social media pressured me to get plastic
surgery
three
two
one
go
like this is something i knew i wanted
no matter what
nothing could have like forced me to do
it because it's something i wanted so
bad as i got older i kind of learned
that like
i literally don't give a when
anybody like tells me about myself
because i know who i am hell yeah
as you should
when i started 40 some years ago there
was no internet
and i just did it it was my own
obsession i've been in the media a lot
and i've done shows about plastic
surgery before and i've noticed that
people who didn't have it 30 years ago
whatever and now all the kids have it
now i feel like it's also hard to tell
what is my own idea of beauty like what
is influence from society and what is my
own perception because i struggle with
this all the time i'm like i think to
myself well i got plastic surgery
because i wanted plastic surgery but
then i think further i'm like well do i
want to look this way because of media
but i do at the end of the day feel like
we all
have like a subjective opinion on beauty
you know i just feel like everyone makes
it out to seem like oh you got plastic
surgery because you know all the
instagram models made you feel like you
needed it but i really truly believe
that there are people who just you know
genuinely like that appearance like in
your case it resonates with them the
results of my surgeries were exactly
what i expected
three
two
one
go
although i'm super happy with both of my
procedures
i
they're not perfect being in the adult
industry i've had people point it out to
me in my videos and like clown on my
i'm still looking so
and um so that you know has definitely
made me a little insecure however if i
didn't get that lift then my would be
really saggy the only surgery that i
did that i got that i didn't expect the
results was my reassignment surgery
i actually was really desperate so i
flew to thailand by myself i didn't
realize it would take almost like a full
year to fully recover and i wasn't
prepared to enter womanhood because you
know i don't have a mom that taught me
that stuff
so
i would oh it's hard i can't even look
at my for a year
but it was just it was really hard
because i was always i was always so
hard on myself because my my brothers
would say really disgusting to me like
saying oh why did you even get that
surgery why did you even cut off that
part of yourself like now you just have
like a festering hole and it just smells
and it's disgusting and how old were you
i was 19. oh that's very young yeah i
was 19 too i've had so many surgeries
that some have been goods and been bad
but i never blamed the doctor you know
and i've had some quacks work on me you
know and they up but
you know what i just live with it and
just you know you can go ahead and when
that heals a little bit go ahead and go
to someone else if you're not happy i
really like how you recognize that and
you don't like you don't blame the
doctor oh i don't blame another doctor
now why should i you know
because they could do the same procedure
on me and with you and we could have i
could get an infection and yeah screw it
totally implanted whatever my subtle
difference
i feel like i was happy before but
i just put on
like a real bra to go out the other
night and like the joy that it brought
me like i literally almost could have
cried because like it was something i
wanted for so long that it it genuinely
made me happy like it wasn't like i was
sad before how much did this go for now
well my surgery was 6 400. so it wasn't
that bad 64. yeah my happiness really is
not based on my plastic surgery did i
add confidence oh a hundred percent yes
i was happy before and if they were
taken away tomorrow honestly
it would suck but i will still be happy
i will still be there it's okay i'm
alive that's all that matters you'd be
pissed let's be real no i will be pissed
for a while bro but eventually like if
that's how it has to be definitely okay
whatever like i'm alive at the end of
the day you know like it was a choice it
was a cosmetic surgery it's not
something that like i needed you know
something that i wanted and i chose to
have
[Applause]
[Music]
i think you are super brave super strong
so